ciao a tutti avete presente gli autobus
bene nemmeno io secondo le antiche
leggende che autobus sono delle specie
di taxi però più grandi il cui compito è
quello di scarrozzanti per la città
l'unica differenza cui tax e che sono
pieni di gente ti portano dove vogliono
loro e fondamentalmente non esistono
secondo le antiche leggende praticamente
gli autobus sono quel mezzo di trasporto
che dopo un mese di abbonamento dovrebbe
farti venire voglia di prendere la
patente a guidare questi bolidi solo
questi esseri mistici che si chiamano
conducenti ora i conducenti sono un
pochino come caronte solamente che
caronte traghettava i morti nel regno
dei morti mentre invece conducenti
traghettano persona che puzzano e morto
nel regno dei vivi
senza contare che come la cometa halley
il periodo di rivoluzione di un autobus
si aggira attorno ai 75 anni che rende
effettivamente un suo passaggio un
evento straordinario e bisogna
attrezzarsi in maniera adeguata
se vi siete fatti la doccia la mattina
non potete salire ogni fermata non a
caso è dotata di un pratico marciapiede
di quale potete rotolarmi in modo da
ottenere quel quel tanfo di sacco nero
dell'umido quel puzzo di bar a quell
alcolico invecchiato quattro fermate e
questo è fondamentale affinché l'autobus
possa portare a termine il compito del
quale è stato progettato ossia a
toglierti la gioia di vivere nel momento
esatto in cui ci entri naturalmente
questa accortezza è valida solamente per
milano perché dal centro in giù è
completamente diverso gli autobus non
esistono sono tipo la camera dei segreti
appaiono solamente se parli serpente se
a roma per esempio gli autobus sono
solamente degli ologrammi non a caso
nelle fermate non ci sono le panchine ma
mettono direttamente delle delle zone
per piantare i picchetti delle tende
alcune fermate hanno pure dei barbecue
per arrostire la carne così al volo
quale fermate degli autobus non hanno
quei bei cartelli luminosi che ti dicono
tra quanti minuti passera autobus no no
no qua ci sono dei poster direttamente
con la scritta mai calcolate che il
periodo del liceo io l'ho trascorso ad
aspettare l'autobus se qualcuno potesse
ridare indietro il tempo che io ho
sprecato da aspettare l'autobus molto
probabilmente dovrei ancora finire lo
sviluppo che poi sapete
qual è la cosa più brutta dell'aspettare
l'autobus per ore e ore di fila quando
l'autobus arriva e già lo vede in
lontananza così per collare su un lato
come michael jackson nel video in cui fa
la mossa di smooth criminal secondo me
l'ha immediatamente aspettava l'autobus
un po come thriller che su tutti i
cadaveri parto di calcoli balistici
perché secondo il teorema di pitagora il
pagato la stretta sul tappeto x la
fermata dell'autobus pu mediante
giramento di quelli che hai fatto ti do
vrà esattamente il punto in cui si
apriranno le porte e mentre stanno tutti
quantificabile con la calcolatrice
patetica parlato vedi che le porte si
aprono e schizzano fuori come se fosse
capodanno vecchi bambini donne che
partoriscono in quel momento ti chiedi
perché perché non puoi sparare le
persone nell'area comando perché non è
portato un bel lanciafiamme da casa ma
soprattutto perché la gente esiste nel
momento in cui sale sull'autobus
timbrare il biglietto è inutile perché
tanto se lo timbri non verrà chiarita
nessuno i controllori salgono solamente
quando non ce l'hai perché come fanno ma
è molto semplice loro subiscono un
addestramento marziale per 12 mesi di
somministrano acqua e cipolla in questi
labirinti bui dove si uccidono a vicenda
tipo hunger games vince la carica di
controllore solamente chi riesce a
uscire vivo da questi posti
collezionando le carte d'identità di
tutti i cadaveri come una scuola può
sentire una goccia di sangue nell'oceano
così il controllore riesce a sentire la
paura della multa va dritto alla meta se
tu hai il biglietto loro non ti si
cagano proprio se poi è l'abbonamento
proprio non esiste nemmeno senza contare
che se per assurdo riesce a salire
sull'autobus e per assurdo non perdi
sensi sbattendo la testa mentre il
controllore guida tipo schumacher e se
per assurdo proprio riesci a trovare
così un angolino nel quale sederti stai
tranquillo che la fermata dopo salirà
sull'autobus villa arzilla al completo
seguita da uno stormo di partorienti e
mutilati di guerra ea nulla servirà a
fingere
dormire le vecchie ti sveglieranno
bastonate che obbligheranno ad alzarti
per farle sedere mentre mutilati di
guerra cercheranno di impietosi arti
sciorinando di la storia della loro vita
con tanto di presentazione powerpoint
che si portano da casa per assurdo sono
donne in città quelli che deve
costringere a sedersi io ormai ho perso
le speranze non mi sento più in autobus
io esco con uno tutto in velcro aspetto
che passi l'autobus e mi ci lancia miss
appiccico tipo jacko scherzi a parte
torniamo per un momento seri gli autobus
si si possono criticare un sacco però
hanno un pregio hanno una caratteristica
che secondo me nessun altro mezzo di
trasporto a diciamo che secondo me
proprio una particolarità loro che è
meravigliosa che è quella di sognare
va beh non ce l'hanno